wanna know what you look like at 70 well
there's a science for that hello and
welcome back to the lab where we take
your questions and turn them into
experiments my name is Mitch and my name
is Gregor today we are talking about AJ
but before we start we want to remind
everyone that our paperback book comes
out in a few days on December 1st it's
cheaper it's a little bit new little
Machane better time your time yes so
yeah make sure you check that out we'll
put links in the description it's on the
Internet it'll be in bookstores so check
it out did you know that there are parts
of the world where they don't even keep
track of their specific age for example
they're like I was born I think in this
spring I mean that might seem kind of
weird until you realize it's also weird
that in a place like Canada you have to
go around the Sun 19 times before you
can drink alcohol the main reason that
scientists keep track of age is that
it's useful for making predictions for
example 40 spins around the Sun and it's
about time you should be getting checked
for prostate and breast cancer and for
the average Canadian your 81st spin
around the Sun is usually your last
don't uh so today we thought we would
age ourselves with some interesting
software now there are a lot of other
apps and stuff out there that can aid
you but what we're gonna use is
something called April age progression
image launcher oh you did it we had
trouble remembering that a genome huh so
essentially these are landmarks that
will take this template face on the left
and put it over Mitch's face to age it
most accurate yeah I don't have the best
future to look forward to so it's
interesting that the sun exposure isn't
really doing anything to my skin but it
sort of makes sense because if you have
darker skin or black skin you have sort
of an extra protection from your elastin
and collagen breaking down but let's see
then what I look like with smoking and
weather yeah stuff like that Oh midge
looks so much more like you've really
really
and also like dog smell now let's go
through the ages and see what you'll
look like as a handsome 40 year old dad
the exact same how about 1 in 60 so it
turns out that I don't have the best
looking a few drops I love you though
ha ha ha Oh kind of look like a serial
killer
I guess the photos of you like very
stern like I really am sensitive to the
Sun it even if I put on SPF 60 I still
burn so well let's do that Oh No did you
like I have you I'm like Blair well like
at smoking Oh son it's just way more
wrinkled yeah holy smokes oh he's gone
holy smokes
Oh oK we've been told that it smoking
affects the collagen and elastin in your
skin which that breaks down which is
holding your skin and making it nice and
tight and beautiful and so smoking
hasn't affected so clearly Helen Mirren
doesn't smell poor she that's plastic
surgery I don't know she's like me lots
of dollars I don't know if she does when
will I be most handsome when do you
think sorry Jesus Pat H already look the
exact same I guess like your shot like
45 I look furrowed brow and like if I
look like a 21 5 again my sweet yeah how
old is Brad Pitt about 60 oh wow you did
a big jump between 45 and 60 where falls
my harsh fears that's when after our
divorce obviously this is the our best
guess there's tons of factors in life
that can change this may be I work out a
little more about some cream for my
cream for my face so we've seen what we
look like using the April software but
we thought it'd be really interesting to
see in person what will look like older
so we're gonna get some professional
makeup done to Benjamin Button ourselves
and make us look really old
oh my god
and like I'm dying so yeah I think the
concept of age is really interesting and
in fact it's just a really great way for
society and scientists to make
predictions and also be able to
understand what you know is supposed to
happen to you in your health over time
there was some really interesting
research where they found that if they
looked at the genes in say your muscle
tissue or your brain tissue they can
more accurately assess how old those
parts of your body were biologically but
what we thought would be fun to see if
we could do with the old-fashioned way
predict our age just by looking at our
childhood photos oh my god is this like
a model shot what it was he was a time
in my past
do you like fifty years ago I don't know
I don't know I guess I was like going
auditions and oh my god so this is like
stage men um I think you're oh my god
wait I was gonna say five but you have
to be older than that I think you are
ten I think you are 11 yeah babe ah emo
haircut
okay I think you're sixteen no 17 yeah
when I see myself in the mirror I'm like
I look the same and then you see these
photos and you're like oh god what has
happened to me oh we're going like this
in like no time what are you wearing
yeah they was like Chris was trying to
like the pageant and like I was one of
those like weird people bring glamour oh
my gosh that's such a hard age I think
you are 14 and no uh 15 yeah okay
you look so different all of them
you have orange hair I think that you
are three in this photo yeah oh my god
you know what'd be interesting if we
took our baby or youth photos and put
them into April like the oh the image
software oh my god see if we look now
predict what we look like
haha it kind of looks like me if I like
did a bunch of drugs
yeah what's interesting is that
software's like this are actually used
by agencies like mi6 or by agencies that
are looking for missing children who
might have been gone for a few years or
many years and then they want to project
what they'll look like in today's age to
help find them and see if they're still
around alright my turn but it we should
say that the software does recommend not
to use photos where you're smiling but I
didn't really have any that were face on
when I wasn't smiling it still is like
you yeah but you look like I look more
like a I feel like it looked like an
ogre or something and that that point
missing teeth seems more normal right
yeah thank you for coming on this aging
experience with us clearly these were
just predictions and actually know the
true way we're gonna look we're just
gonna have to make it to 72
you